we have a guest here and before you
don't even say anything until I bring
your name up okay okay thank you thank
you so much it was a little bit of
sabotage because I wanted this guy
before my brother and all of a sudden my
brother's DB Wiebe had him out as a
guest and I felt a little bit of a
Shakespearean betrayal I understand that
their relationship you know they have a
relationship they've known each other
for 10 years or whatever but still I
feel like I'm still the bigger name I
really believe that I think nationally I
think I might be you know people on
YouTube and people on the internet and
they go Stevie B's the funny or brother
yeah nah all right [ __ ] it all right I
love my brother but we've got um how
about a round of applause for Jonathan
Park everybody down in the park I'm
better known as dumbfounded yeah yeah
dumbfounded why Jonathan's in the house
right I refuse to call you dumb poundage
oh no it's all good I mean I refuse to
acknowledge myself as dumbfounded at 32
I just hit that yeah rah rah I think
names are kind of like it's weird with
it so people call you dumb they do what
else do they call you just John dumb
pretty much but I don't live on dummy no
no no I can't call you dummy
if my mom's trying to be cute she'll be
like hi dummy let's say that yeah but
like I actually two years ago I almost
did like a name change thing were you
thinking I actually did try it like I
pushed it hard
what was that was Parker oh that's a
good name
I literally went off pretty much off my
last name Park yeah I think I'm gonna
make it white it knows like yeah I kind
of wanted like a real name kind of
situation nickname yeah so I went for
Parker and in my fans was like no you're
dumbfounded like they would not let me
change it have you gone by in the past
or what other like it's literally since
I was 14 dumbfounded
was like my rap name yeah and then like
two three years ago like I went to that
I was like ah man I got it I gotta do
something about this you know I don't
know if I could pop off as a dumbfounded
you know so I try to Parker and I have
meat stickers and t-shirts and
everything I got one what what is it ul
thin upper lip no one has pointed out my
thin upper lip and rats you ever me like
like when I see my pictures and I'm like
yeah yeah I'll notice it you know yeah
yeah but no one has ever like pointed
that out if you have to like then why I
respect you right but I ain't afraid
okay I'm not I know you bring game I
know that you have follower all right
but let me tell you something a little
weird thing what I just did no what you
just pointed out guys no one's pointed
that out
yeah I've like a bad thing it's not a
bad thing I just noticed it you know are
you offended wait no one called no one
has ever called that out one of your rap
battles no like I mean that's a specific
thing a point I'm noticing that doesn't
sound like a hard date like if you're
like trying to attack me and you notice
that gangster horn your upper lip is
tiny [ __ ]
no one's gonna go like oh they're just
gonna be like why is Bobby
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you know I have a weird thing like that
I I noticed different things like I saw
Chris D'Elia earlier today and he has
like 15 veins on his right temple
there's like it's his skin is
translucent up here so when he gets
angry
you see these veins pop up and I always
go that's [ __ ] weird and he goes why
do you notice that I go I don't know I
just do yeah you know like I noticed
boils I notice freckles I'm a big
freckle man myself
those aren't freckles on your faces or
liver spots did I [ __ ] [ __ ] did I just
did I just what a [ __ ] Gorge girl is
getting a charger [ __ ] did I say that I
counted my own freckles on my face no
because I thought you were trying to
pass your liver spots first no I already
played a [ __ ] already yo yo down I
don't leave a spot on the face in case
you wanna wonder about it I think he's
turning up the hip-hop if you don't know
if you're not familiar with urban Bob
yeo-hwa sad dog she raised the roof dog
[Laughter]
[Music]